digamos que tenemos una pelota de
básquetbol que se dirige hacia una bola
de helado de cacahuate y chispas de
chocolate así que ambas van a colisionar
y hay diferentes maneras de caracterizar
esta colisión y una de las cosas que
casi siempre les interesa a los físicos
es saber si esta colisión va a ser
elástica o inelástica ya qué nos
referimos con una colisión elástica
bueno en una colisión elástica la
energía cinética se conserva y no me
refiero a la energía cinética de uno de
los objetos me refiero a la energía
cinética de todos los objetos así que
esa es la energía cinética total la
energía cinética de todos los objetos en
la colisión se conserva y algunas
personas les confunde este término de
que se conserva es una palabra elegante
para decir que la energía cinética se va
a mantener constante es decir que va a
tener el mismo valor antes y después de
la colisión y podemos poner esto en un
enunciado matemático podemos decir que
toda la energía cinética se conserva
aquí
vamos a escribir que la energía cinética
de la bola de basketball antes de la
colisión y aquí usamos la letra k para
representar la energía cinética y esa es
la energía cinética de la bola antes de
la colisión y lo expresamos como cabe y
que es la energía cinética inicial de la
bola el primer subíndice representa el
objeto en este caso la pelota de
básquetbol y el segundo subíndice
representa el momento en este caso es
antes de la colisión la energía cinética
inicial y como nos interesa la energía
cinética total vamos a agregarle a este
la energía cinética del helado y cómo es
una super bola de helado voy a poner el
subíndice s para representar la y pongo
y porque es inicial su energía cinética
antes de la colisión con esto
representamos la energía cinética total
antes de la colisión y podemos hacer lo
mismo para representar la energía
cinética total después de la colisión
seguramente la pelota de basquetbol va a
seguir moviéndose después de la colisión
por lo que va a tener una energía
cinética final y si a esto le agregamos
la energía cinética que tendrá la bola
de helado después de la colisión todo
esto de acá será la energía cinética
total después de la colisión y si la
colisión es elástica significa que toda
la energía cinética se va a conservar
quiere decir que esta energía cinética
total inicial va a ser igual a la
energía cinética total final estas son
iguales si tenemos una colisión elástica
esto es lo que significa una colisión
elástica la energía cinética total se va
a conservar y para una colisión
inelástica la energía cinética total no
se va a conservar
en otras palabras esta expresión no se
va a mantener esta expresión si la
colisión es inelástica diremos que la
energía cinética inicial va a ser
diferente de la energía cinética final y
para la mayoría de las colisiones sin
elásticas la energía cinética total
inicial va a ser mayor que la energía
cinética total final en una colisión
inelástica vamos a perder energía
cinética ya que parte de esta energía
cinética se va a transformar en otro
tipo de energía y esa energía
típicamente es energía térmica pues
imagínense que esta bola de helado se
estrella contra la pelota de basquetbol
esta bola de helado está formada por
átomos y moléculas deliciosos átomos y
moléculas y no es que estas masas estén
conectadas entre sí por resortes pero
podemos imaginar que va a tener sus
moléculas y átomos conectados entre sí
por resortes
aunque en realidad estos resortes son
fuerza electromagnética
aquí tenemos enlaces químicos que están
ocurriendo pero todo esto es algo
complicado así que vamos a simplificarlo
imaginando que esto está unido por
resortes imaginen que esta colisión
sucede y esta molécula o átomo va a
comenzar a vibrar esta otra también va a
comenzar a oscilar más y ahora que estos
átomos y moléculas tienen mayor energía
cinética en sí mismos por esta energía
térmica aleatoria la energía cinética
total de esta bola de helado que tenía
al ir hacia acá va a disminuir ya que
parte de esa energía va a estar
distribuida aleatoriamente entre los
átomos y moléculas que forman esta bola
de helado y ahora si esta bola de helado
no estuviera tan fría estos resortes no
serían tan duros por lo que los átomos y
moléculas se moverían como quisieran de
manera que mucha de la energía cinética
se transformaría en energía térmica pero
si esta bola de helado está congelada si
la sacamos directamente
en el congelador entonces estos enlaces
van a estar mucho más duros y estos
átomos y moléculas se mantendrán en su
lugar al menos en comparación de como lo
harían si estuvieran a mayor temperatura
y una vez que esta estructura se vuelve
más rígida va a ser más difícil
transferir la energía cinética a estos
átomos individuales por lo que se
volverá cada vez más elástico ya que
desperdiciaremos menos energía cinética
en esta energía térmica y si llevamos
esto al extremo y tenemos en lugar de
una bola de helado una bola de hierro
estos enlaces entre los átomos van a ser
tremendamente rígidos y con esto nos
estaremos aproximando a una colisión que
sea elástica ya que tendríamos la
energía cinética total final casi igual
a la energía cinética total inicial y yo
en su lugar diría a ver un momento cómo
es que no se está conservando aquí la
energía cinética acabamos de decir que
esa energía cinética de la colisión se
va a transformar en energía cinética en
los átomos y seguimos teniendo energía
cinética la energía térmica en su mayor
parte sigue siendo energía cinética y en
efecto la energía térmica en su mayor
parte es energía cinética es decir quizá
también podremos tener algo de energía
potencial por aquí o por allá y otros
tipos de energía pero la energía térmica
en su mayor parte es energía cinética
así que debemos hacer una distinción
cuando decimos que se conserva la
energía cinética total nos referimos a
la energía cinética de ese objeto
macroscópico del objeto que se está
moviendo en cierta dirección las
velocidades a las que nos referimos en
estas colisiones son las velocidades de
los objetos macroscópicos en este caso
la velocidad de la bola de helado en sí
misma no de la de los átomos y moléculas
individuales
en otras palabras no vamos a incluir los
movimientos y oscilaciones aleatorias
que tengan estos átomos y moléculas
al menos no las incluimos en este
cálculo de acá de otra forma
básicamente todas las colisiones serían
elásticas ya que esa energía cinética
macroscópica se transformaría en energía
cinética microscópica pero aquí arriba
estamos hablando de energía cinética
macroscópica la de todo el objeto
moviéndose en cierta dirección para
dejar esto más claro veamos un ejemplo
con números digamos que la pelota de
básquetbol y la bola de helado tienen
cierta velocidad antes de la colisión
digamos que la bola de basketball va
hacia la derecha con una rapidez de 10
metros por segundo antes de la colisión
y la bola de helado va hacia la
izquierda a 8 metros por segundo y
digamos que después de la colisión esta
pelota de básquetbol se sigue moviendo
hacia la derecha pero se está moviendo a
1 metro por segundo y digamos que la
bola de helado rebota y ahora va en
sentido contrario a 5 metros por segundo
la masa de la pelota de básquetbol es
más o menos de 0.65 kilogramos y ahora
con esta masa de la bola de basquetbol
tengo que elegir la masa correcta de mi
bola de helado ya que estas velocidades
las elegía aleatoriamente para conservar
el momento de esta colisión y casi todas
las colisiones deben de conservar
momento la masa de esta bola de helado
debe ser de 0.45 kilogramos ahora sí con
estas cantidades nos podemos preguntar
esa colisión es el
o inelástica y un error muy común es que
las personas dicen bueno estos van a
rebotar
entonces si rebotan pues la colisión es
elástica esta bola de basketball se va a
la derecha la bola de helado también
está yendo a la derecha por lo que
debieron haber chocado y separado acaso
no significa esto que la colisión fue
elástica y no esto no quiere decir que
sea elástico por el solo hecho de
rebotar entre sí esto no implica que se
tiene una colisión elástica aunque si se
cumple lo opuesto si la colisión es
elástica entonces siempre debe de
rebotar pero no por el solo hecho de
rebotar signifique que sea elástico así
que aquí debemos tener cuidado como
podemos saber si la colisión fue
elástica pues simplemente verificamos si
la energía cinética total se conservó
veamos qué pasa aquí tenemos suficientes
cantidades como para hacer este cálculo
uso la fórmula de energía cinética que
es un medio por m por b al cuadrado y
así puedo encontrar cuál fue la energía
cinética
de la pelota de básquetbol es un medio
por la masa de la pelota por la
velocidad inicial de esta pelota que fue
de 10 aquí estoy usando las velocidades
iniciales ya que quiero encontrar la
energía cinética inicial y como quiero
la energía cinética total a esto le
tengo que agregar la energía cinética de
la bola de helado más un medio de la
masa de la bola de helado por su
velocidad inicial al cuadrado que fue de
8 metros por segundo y que al caso esta
cantidad no sería negativa por la
dirección de la velocidad bueno cómo
vamos a elevar las al cuadrado pues
realmente no importa si calculamos todo
esto nos quedan 46.9 jules que es
nuestra energía cinética total inicial
será esto igual a la cantidad final
vamos a verlo para encontrar la energía
cinética final tengo que tomar la
velocidad final de la pelota de
básquetbol un medio por la masa de la
pelota por su velocidad final que fue de
un metro por segundo
lo pongo al cuadrado y a esto le
agregamos la energía cinética final de
la bola de helado que va a ser un medio
por la masa de la bola de helado por su
velocidad final que fue de 5 metros por
segundo al cuadrado si hacemos los
cálculos nos queda que esto es igual a
5.95 jules de energía cinética total
final entonces esta colisión fue
elástica no para nada ni siquiera se
acercó esta energía cinética total
inicial fue de 46.9 jules esta energía
cinética total final fue de 5.95 jules
la energía cinética aquí no se conservó
por lo que consideramos esta colisión
como inelástica pero si son inteligentes
ustedes podrían haber observado
solamente los números de aquí sin tener
que hacer todos los cálculos que
acabamos de hacer y pueden decir a ver
la pelota de básquetbol comenzó con una
rapidez de 10 metros por segundo y
terminó con una rapidez de 1 metro por
segundo
definitivamente tiene menos energía
cinética al final que la que tenía al
principio y esta bola de helado comenzó
con una rapidez de 8 metros por segundo
y terminó con una rapidez de solo 5
metros por segundo por lo que también
terminó con menos energía cinética de la
que tenía al principio entonces esta
energía cinética total tiene que ser
menor que la energía cinética total
inicial y se pueden preguntar a dónde
fue esa energía cinética que faltó pues
se fue a la energía térmica de las
moléculas y átomos que componen a los
objetos que colisionaron estos átomos y
moléculas van a vibrar más de lo que
vibraban antes de que ocurriera la
colisión
de la misma forma ondas de sonidos que
fueron creadas por esta colisión van a
quitar algo de la energía cinética hay
muchas formas en las que se puede
escapar la energía y en particular en
este ejemplo se perdió bastante energía
cinética por lo que seguramente hubo
muchas formas en las que se escapó así
que tenemos una colisión inelástica
en resumen para que una colisión sea
elástica el que los objetos rebote no es
suficiente tenemos que ver si la energía
cinética inicial total es igual a la
energía cinética total final si este es
el caso entonces tendremos una colisión
elástica y si este no es el caso
entonces tendremos una colisión
inelástica y como nota final quizás
ustedes se encuentren con el término
perfectamente elástico al menos en lo
que se refiere a las colisiones lo que
es algo redundante es otra forma de
decir que realmente la energía cinética
inicial es prácticamente igual a la
energía cinética final pero en otras
ocasiones nos encontraremos con el
término perfectamente inelástico y esto
es significativo quiere decir que los
objetos que colisionaron se quedaron
pegados si es perfectamente inelástico
quiere decir que los objetos quedan
juntos y ahora se mueven como una sola
unidad en otras palabras si esta bola de
helado se hubiera quedado pegada a la
bola de basketball
se movieran hacia la derecha a cierta
velocidad tendríamos una colisión
perfectamente inelástica y ahora ya sea
elástica o inelástica el momento se va a
seguir conservando para estas colisiones
si esta colisión ocurre en un intervalo
corto de tiempo no tendremos una fuerza
externa que tenga el tiempo suficiente
para intervenir así que si tenemos una
colisión que ocurra casi
instantáneamente el momento se va a
conservar tanto para las colisiones
elásticas como para las colisiones y
elásticas a veces las personas se
confunden y piensan que bueno la energía
se tiene que conservar cuando tenemos
una colisión elástica quizás eso
significa que también el momento solo se
va a conservar en las colisiones
elásticas pero esto no es así el momento
se va a conservar para ambos tipos de
colisiones y ustedes si son inteligentes
me pueden decir a ver a ver a ver un
momento en las colisiones inelástica
estamos perdiendo todo tipo de energía
que sé
ir hacia las oscilaciones aleatorias de
los elementos microscópicos en este
material
acaso no vamos a perder también momento
ya que el movimiento implica tanto la
energía cinética como el momento así que
porque no estamos perdiendo un momento
en esas colisiones sin elásticas y la
razón es que las oscilaciones aleatorias
en los átomos y moléculas de este
material están oscilando precisamente de
forma aleatoria en direcciones
aleatorias esta energía térmica se está
distribuyendo de forma aleatoria por lo
que el momento en los átomos y moléculas
en esta estructura se van a cancelar ya
que si tenemos momento en todas
direcciones y el momento es un vector
esto nos va a dar igual a que no hay
momento o al menos no hay momento neto
pues todas estas se van a cancelar entre
sí ésta se cancela con esta aquella con
esta otra por lo que en cualquier
colisión inelástica no vamos a tener
pérdida del momento total al menos no
con los elementos microscópicos del
pero si habrá pérdida de energía
cinética ya que la energía cinética es
escalar es decir la energía cinética no
tiene dirección por lo que esta energía
no puede cancelarse de esta manera no es
un vector así que aunque en las
colisiones sin elásticas perdemos
energía cinética por los átomos y
moléculas a nivel microscópico no vamos
a perder ningún momento neto por esos
mismos elementos ya que todo este
momento se cancela así que el movimiento
total de esos objetos macroscópicos se
va a mantener va a mantener el momento
total y esto es una excelente noticia ya
que el momento se va a conservar tanto
para las colisiones elásticas como para
las in elásticas no importa qué tipo de
colisión sea el momento se va a
conservar siempre y cuando no haya
tiempo de que otra fuerza pueda
intervenir a algún otro impulso externo
así que aunque solamente la energía se
puede conservar en una colisión elástica
el momento se va a conservar para
cualquier tipo de colisión